we thank you very much uh for joining uh
sir patrick and
jonathan van tan in london and me here
in
isolation in buckinghamshire today we've
reached the fourth
step on our roadmap and i know that with
cases increasing
steadily and with more and more people
being asked to self-isolate
there will of course be those uh who
would rather that we'd
waited weeks or months longer and kept
on
social distancing and all the legal
restrictions that we've been
placing on our lives and so
i want to remind you all why i believe
that
it's right to take this step now no
matter how difficult
it seems and the logic remains the same
if we don't open up now
then we face a risk of even tougher
conditions
in the colder months when the virus has
a natural
advantage we lose that fire break of the
school holidays
and there comes a point after
so many have been vaccinated
when further restrictions no longer
prevent
hospitalizations and deaths but simply
delay the inevitable and so
we have to ask ourselves the question
if not now when and though
both deaths and hospitalizations as i
say are sadly
rising these numbers are
well within the margins of what our
scientists predicted
at the outset of the roadmap and so
it is right to proceed cautiously in the
way
that we are but it's also right to
recognize
that this pandemic is far from over and
that's why
i'm afraid it is essential to keep up
the system
of test face and isolate and i
know how frustrating it is for all those
who have been affected or pinged
and i want to explain therefore
that people identified as contacts of
cases
are at least five times more likely
to be infected than others and
even if they've been vaccinated there is
a significant risk
that they can still pass the disease on
and so as we go forward i'm afraid
that the continuing sacrifice of this
large minority those of us who are being
asked to isolate
remains important to allow the rest of
society
to get back to something like normality
and i'm afraid at this stage it's simply
a consequence of living with kogit
and of opening up when cases are high in
the way
that we are as you know we'll be moving
on august the 16th to a system of
testing
rather than isolation for those who are
double vaccinated by which time of
course we hope that the
wall of immunity in our country will be
even higher
and in the meantime i want to
assure you that we will protect crucial
services including the starting of our
hospitals and our
our care homes the supplies of food
water
electricity and medicines the running of
our trains
the uh protection of our borders the
defense of our realm
by making sure that a small number a
very small number
of named fully vaccinated critical
workers are able to leave their
isolation
solely for the work that i have
described
but for the vast majority of us myself
included we do need
to stick with the system for now and
of course the only reason that we're
able to open up
in this way at all is that we vaccinated
such a large
proportion of the population and at
such speed it is phenomenal that every
adult in this country has now been
offered
a first dose but unfortunately
that does not mean that every person
over 18
has yet hacked a first dose so far
96 over 50s 83
of 30 to 50 year olds have taken up the
offer
in england but there are still 35
of 18 to 30 year olds of three million
people
who are at the moment completely
unvaccinated
and then we can all see the enthusiasm
of millions
of young people to get their jabs
we need even more young adults
to receive a protection that is of
immense benefit
to your family and friends and to
yourselves
and so i would remind everybody that
some of life's most
important pleasures and opportunities
are likely to be increasingly dependent
on vaccination
there are already countries that require
you
already to be double jabbed as a
condition
of quarantine free travel and i'm afraid
that list
seems likely to grow and we're also
concerned as they are in other countries
by the continuing risk posed by
nightclubs i don't want to have to close
nightclubs again as they have elsewhere
but it does mean nightclubs need to do
the socially responsible thing
and make use of the nhs kogi pass which
shows
proof of vaccination recent
negative test or natural immunity as a
means
of entry as we said last week
we do reserve the right to mandate
certification at any point
if it's necessary to reduce transmission
and
i should serve notice now that by the
end of september when
all over 18s will have had their chance
to be double jab we're planning to make
full vaccination
the condition of entry to nightclubs and
other venues
where large crowds gather proof of a
negative test will no longer be enough
now let me stress we want people to
be able to take back their freedoms
as they can today we want this country
to be able to enjoy the fruits of our
massive efforts and of our
enormous vaccination campaign
but to do that we must remain
cautious and we must continue
to get vaccinated and that's why we're
asking you to come forward
and get your jabs no